All right guys in this video. I will teach you how to use statement deviation projections
Sand deviation is a very very powerful tool you can
mayor your
Accumulation phases actually not the accumulation phase
But you can mayor the manipulation phase and then you can also mayor the expansion phase
And then you can make your reversals or continuations
this is very very powerful and
and
We we use this with a power of three. So
Remember one thing that every single candle has a power of three. It's gonna have accumulation manipulation and distribution
Whenever you see a candle, it's gonna have a wick
Right either to the one side or both sides. So it's gonna have a wick here could have a wick here
Right. So let's say this was the opening price
Price manipulates to the upside and then expands to the downside. So that is called power of three
Now what if I told you that by standard deviation projections, you can mayor the
Manipulation so you will know where the manipulation phase ends
And you will also know where the expansion ends
So you can look to take both trades or you can look to take the trade after
The manipulation now keep in mind that
We trade this with auto flow. So if the auto flow is bearish
we
are primarily want to see a
Manipulation to the buy side liquidity. So I want to see price go up manipulate and then expand to the downside
So when you you combine auto flow with this then your win rate will significantly improve. So what exactly is standard deviation
right
so let's assume that
and also
I personally use this with power of three, but you can also use this with key levels. So
This could be let's say that there is a key level here could be a hard time from auto block
Right could be a friendly gap and price goes into your
Key level
And then gives you a market structure shift
Now to mayor where the price is going to go from here what you can do is use your Fibonacci tool
Use from the top
To the high so use it from the last high
To the last low that was formed before market structure shift
Now
Let me turn on some numbers here. So it's gonna be one one point five
And this should be okay
So this is the key level price goes into the key level gives you a shift in the market structure. So now
Look at this negative two and negative two point five percent level also make sure you copy all these numbers, okay
Keep your focus on the negative two and negative two point five
So I think let's just do this like that
Okay
so
The negative two and negative two point five remember that
Look at the liquidity level below the negative two level
What is a significant liquidity pool? It could be a low could be a high so this is negative two below that
But do we have this?
Liquidy level
This is going to be your final target level if that makes sense so you will be taking your entry
From the fairly gap whatever is presented to you or order block
And you take your take profit level once this liquidity pool is hit
or
Just to be even safer
What I sometimes do is I take my profits at the negative two line. So this over here
Now this level here
Is from where price is going to reverse?
Okay, so whenever this level inside this level price can reverse from this level, okay
But if there are targets that are not met if if the price has some business that is left out
So in this scenario, it is this liquidity level most of the time it's going to take out that liquidity and then reverse
Now price can also expand even further to negative four level
Okay, and this happens when there is a significant target for price to achieve so there could be
You know a higher level of liquidity pool down there near this level
So price can take out this level here as well
But mostly price will reverse from the negative two and negative two point five level
Now let's talk about the silver bullet zones so negative one and negative one point five
inside this level
So once you get like a market structure shift and an entry now if you don't want to enter directly from here
To increase your win rate once price hits the negative one and negative one point five in between here
It should not go below the negative one point five level inside this box
price goes into this level
And
Once it does that you mark out any PD array that is there so it could be a fairly gap here
Could be a breaker block could be an auto block
Once you take your entry
Price will rush towards the main target
That is why it is called standard deviation silver bullet entry
Also when price goes into this level it significantly confirms
That price will not head head towards the main target
So ideally I will not hold till negative four because it is very risky
I will just take my profit at negative two or if there's a closed target
So there could be you know a liquidity level below the negative two which could be just right around here or it could be here
Once price does take that out. I'm out of the trade
Now I will take out some partial so maybe price breaks this level. I will take some partial here grow big grow big agreement
right i'll grow break even here and
Yeah
Now let's talk about how we actually use this with power of three
All right
So in this video, I will teach you a strategy that is included in my upcoming course update
So this strategy uses daily power of three and standard deviation projections
This happens every single day. So the setup is going to be there every single day
So I want you guys to watch the entire video to in order to understand this whole strategy
So 95 percent of the candles are going to have a wake either to the one side or both sides
Right only five percent of the candles will not have a wake and a complete body if that makes sense
So we want to trade
When we have a wake and then we have expansion to the downside. So the wake is mostly a manipulation move
Once the manipulation is over we want to get into the trade somewhere around here and then take the entire trade
Or example, uh, I mean take the entire expansion to the downside if that makes sense, right?
So let's assume that this
candle is a
bearish
Daily candle, okay
So all you have to do is mark out the daily candle opening price
Now once you have marked out the daily candle opening price, you have to drop down to five minute time frame
Once you drop down to five minute time frame, you will have your opening price, right now
The price will first of all manipulate. Okay, so
Let's do let's remove this for now
And we have we will see price consolidate for some time
And then we will have a market structure shift
And then we will have a manipulation
Which as I said before is gonna be a wake, right?
We will see a manipulation move
Now the goal here is to mire the manipulation
We need to know where the manipulation is going to end and to do so we use standard deviation projections
So use your Fibonacci and use your Fibonacci from the last low
And last high that was formed before market structure shifts. So that is the opening price
I want to see price go below this level
Okay, first off. I want to see price go and dip below here
And then give me a market structure shift now it can dip and give me a market structure shift above
The opening price, but it has to go down to some degree
Okay, for example here here and here it went down and then gave you a market structure shift
All right, so you use your Fibonacci from the low
to the high
And you will get these projections. So you can copy these numbers just disable this
Just in case you want to copy these. All right. Once you have these copied
Now you have to put your focus on the negative two negative two point five and negative four
So we are first of all marrying the manipulation moves so
Once price goes to goes above negative two
You have to start looking for a market structure shift
Because from here onwards price will now reverse and expand towards its original direction
If that makes sense
So over here
we had a shift in the market structure, right and
Now we are projecting the manipulation move. So here
it can either
The manipulation move can either end above just above negative two it can end above negative two point five or
It could go even further to negative four, but most is going to be somewhere around here
Now from here onwards what you're looking for is a shift in the market structure
Now once you have a shift in the market structure
You have to now mayor the expansion move and to do so you want to use your Fibonacci from the last high
To the last low that was formed before market structure shift
now
for the target
look below the negative two
And if you have any liquidity level
Any significant liquidity level it could be a low could be a high below the negative two
That is your take profit level
Okay, so you can then take your entry from the break a block
Or a fair value gap or an autoblock. So I usually love to take my entries from autoblock
I would take my entry
I would take some partials around some fair value gap that could be here
And then the last take profit level would be the this liquidity level around here
and
Similarly if we invert the chart here
And let's do this to do
So we have let's say
This is the opening price, right?
and
We are bullish. We want to see like the candle expanded bullish, right?
So this is what it's going to look like on the five-minute time frame
We will see consolidation probably
All you have to do is look for a market structure shift
Once you have a market structure shift, right?
You want to look for you will have to mare the manipulation move
So again from the last high to the last low before market structure shift price dips into this level
Right, and then we get a market structure shift
Then once you get the market structure shift we want to mare the expansion move
and that is going to be
Here, this is the liquidity level
Inside this key zone area above negative two level
Right, this is what you have to this is like the entire strategy guys
So this is how you can mare the the wicks the entire daily power of three that makes sense
This is very easy. I go into more detail in the the update the course a bit video
But this should be enough the what i've taught you here. It should be enough
So let me give you guys some examples and then i'll end the video and also my apologies
Uh, there's no face in this video. I'm a little bit sick
Uh, but yeah, let's let's end this video
All right guys. So here's example number one looking at usdcat on the daily time frame
And we're gonna study today's candle that is still in formation
So marking out the opening price. Let's drop down to five-minute time frame and see what happened
So going back here
What I can see is
This is the opening price and price went up gave us a market structure shift, right?
but
If I use my fib from here to here
Price never went down to negative two and negative 2.5
But it went up swept the liquidity here
Right and then it gave us a market structure shift by breaking this low
So using our refib energy from the last high to the last low
Which you can see price dipped into negative two and negative 2.5
But we didn't get a market structure shift. However, price dipped into negative four
Right and then we had a shift in the market structure
Once we have a shift in the market structure, I can see a clear free value gap down here in the discount
Now to mayor our expansion move we want to use our free from the last low
to last high
And this is negative two here look slightly above it and we have this high over here
That should be a take profit level
So this would have given you around seven rr if you took your trade from this fair value gap
So let's move on to the next example
All right guys, so here's example number two looking at usdcat on the daily time frame
We're gonna study this candle. So let's mark out the opening price and then we drop down to five-minute time frame
Now if I go back here, which you can see this is the opening price of the candle
Price goes up and gives us a market structure shift
So now we want to measure our manipulation move. So let's use our fit from the last high to last low
Price dipped below the negative 2.5 and then gave us a market structure shift before market structure shift
We had a small liquidity sweep as you can see right there
And afterwards we have a shift in the market structure
Now if we look closely, what do we have? We have this fair value gap
We also have this auto block here. So price respected both fair value gap and the auto block
Now to measure our expansion move we can use our fit from the last low to last high
And above the negative 2 we have this liquidity level. So that is going to be our target level
And yes, you can take your entries during asian session for this strategy
So pretty simple guys, uh, let's move on to the next example
All right guys. So here is example number three. I'm looking at ad usd
So this is the open price of the daily candle right here at 17
And you can see that this green candle is both a high and a low
So if you're wondering what indicator i'm using to determine highs and lows go to indicators type in fractals
And
The one by rigility is the one you should use and that's what i'm using. So
We're going to use
From this is the low. This is the high and this gets a market structure shift here
So we're going to use our fit from the last low to last high
And you can see price dipped above the negative 2 but we didn't get any market structure shift here
But then price went above negative 2.5
And from here onwards we had a clean market structure shift and above that we have a very beautiful fairly gap
Now to mayor our expansion move we're going to mayor from the Fibonacci from the last high to last low
And just below the negative 2 we have this
High sorry this low that should be a take profit level
You could have also targeted this but we want to be safe. So we just targeted this
So that's pretty much it guys. It's very easy and mechanical in a way that you can use it every single day on every single pair
Just pick three to four pairs and use this on that on those pairs. Okay